[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build well do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz Ramsey
personality hosting this hour with
bestselling author Ramsey personality Dr
John deloney and we are here to answer
your calls and it's a free call anywhere
in the country at
225 all right we're going to start off
hold wait who who it's launch day yo oh
I was going to get to a call first but
it's launch day we'll jve right head
first into it we finally have a book
that's at my reading level coming out of
this company and I'm excited for it it's
a children's book I'm glad for what I
have so it's my kids book that is out uh
right now so you can you can go and
order beautiful I can't wait to buy them
for all of my family it's amazing it's
really great all about contentment and
great for this holiday season that we're
about to Embark in I know and George is
writing these money books I can't
understand but I can understand this you
can understand this one pictures that's
yes baby squirrels they ask for more and
more they gather as much as their
Burrows would store so ready hey that
looks really great it's really actually
amazing yes thank you so yes I'm glad
for what I have is out today awesome all
right let's see if uh Michael New York
who's up next let's see if Michael has
any kids M Mike m Mike m Michael do you
have any
children uh I got one on the way coming
yes ah good hang on the line we're gonna
send you a book I'm gonna send you my
new kids book for the new baby on the
way okay how far long is your
wife uh very early it's like uh we're
about eight weeks nine weeks something
like that oh my gosh oh this is just now
becoming real I'm the first baby gift I
have a feeling Michael that will be
given to you okay well that's awesome
hang on the line after this call but how
can we
help so um you know since you know me
and my wife got married about two years
ago and she's very reluctant on
attacking her
$120,000 uh student loan debt she
has um right now she's uh you know I'm
willing to help her with it you know I'm
you know I'm definitely there for her to
help her with it but she doesn't want to
make the steps for herself to really
attack it so I wanted you know every
time I bring it up to her she gets you
know a little defensive she doesn't want
to really talk about it so I'm just
trying to get a way to get us on the
same page yeah
uh it's a great question and I think
Michael you know just even the way you
have kind of phrased the situation even
to us it does feel like a his and her
mentality so yeah when you go to her
about her debt it can feel like an
accusation or you know you're you're
wanting something that she doesn't want
and it's about her stuff so that's where
things get really messy and really you
know yeah I I understand why she
probably is feeling the way she is
because I think the mindset that you
guys have not just the student loan debt
but just in general with money and the
way you guys look at this as a team
sitting down and saying hey before like
we're going to talk about the $120,000
student loan debt let's talk about like
the values of our family and our student
to be right family all that that kids
are coming into the picture uh which is
very exciting but hey what what do we
value what do we want as a family do we
want to be debt-free do we want to live
without debt do we want to be a generous
cou like what are these values that we
want to have and out of those values is
where you can make these tactical
decisions like paying off student loan
debt so I think that's one of the bigger
conversations Michael that I would
encourage you guys to have is as a
couple and and and money fights and
money problems I mean this is a big
tension point for people but it's not
just because of the money it's usually
the things underneath it that get
stirred up because values are not
aligned does that make sense sure sure
what um what what shuts her down when
you start having the conversation what
why does she withdraw
um you know I come to her and I'll be
like you know babe you know I'll ask her
cuz I'll be like how's that how's uh
you're doing what your student loan and
she pays it every month hold on I want
to stop you right there I want to stop
you right there are y'all
married yes yeah it's
y'alls yep exactly I totally agree it's
y absolutely so do you have separate
accounts yes we do I'm not a fan of it
I'd rather our accounts be together but
she won't join your accounts with
you she's reluctant why she's reluctant
how come that's a great question we we
we've had that uh conversation before
what dides she say um she's like oh well
you know it's really like spinning the
wheels to be honest with you I couldn't
give you exact uh wording on it I
haven't spoken to her about it in a
little bit so here's a conversation that
happened in my house about 10 or 15
years into being
married M I realized that my dad was a
policeman growing
up and there were Seasons when he would
put his debit card in knowing there was
no money in that account but he had
babies to
feed right and I remember
money being this pulsing neon sign that
told me that my family wasn't
enough and that my dad service his
community wasn't
enough and that I was less than all my
friends cuz they could buy cars and they
could go on
vacations and so I didn't want to talk
about money and I thought it was
fighting my wife and I wasn't what I was
fighting was my
childhood sure and the only way we got
to that conversation was the time my
wife said the words John I am scared to
death and it took the air out of my
lungs and so I think there's a
conversation to have about hey have you
paid your thing have I paid my thing and
dude like Rachel said y'all will dance
around this thing Forever Until you have
a baby and then it will be like I want
to have it at home I want to have it at
the hospital I want right and then it's
just going to go on and on it's getting
to that that underneath thing that
Rachel was talking about hey honey sure
I feel like you have your life and I
have my life and we're about to have a
baby and I've been coming at you with
numbers and plans and your money and my
money I'm scared to death we are going
to create a life that we just co-manage
as household and I want to do life as
one will you join me in that you see
what I'm saying that's you taking a knee
because and let's say this true what
your plan hasn't worked the way you've
tried hasn't worked try because she
won't if she doesn't want to do it she
don't have to do it you know the way
it's set up but it's it's not like it's
just odd to me because it's not like we
make bad money we make decent money it
has it has nothing to do with that all
that does is buy you some margin to be a
little more stupid and a little more
separate right if you both are making $7
an hour you have to pull this money
because you can't you can't this y
because y'all make good money it allows
y'all to do stupid for
longer yeah Michael and I think too you
know if if I was in this situation and
my husband came to me and just said and
it and it's a instead of a pointing
fingers accusation it is it's it's a
different posture honestly of the
conversation of saying God what is
underneath that babe like what what what
is the thing that scares you so much
that is making you so hesitant not just
to pay the bills but for us to be
together as a team that's almost Michael
more concerning to me than just $120,000
student loan bill which needs to be paid
but this this mindset shift so I would
want knowing in in humility and kindness
Michael that you want to know her like
you want to you want to know what's
going on and having that conversation
with her and then on a very tactical
side just to give give you something
even pull together your income and just
say hey how long map out how long would
it take us to pay this off if we like
really dove in and like at least give
some kind of plan and let that even be a
tactical step too because sometimes this
idea in your head of paying off it's
like I don't know how I don't know what
the first step is but if you initiated
that even it could be a jumping off
point too into the conversation but hey
we're going to give you Ramsey uh we're
going to give you FPU as our gift to you
yeah hold on the line we'll give you the
book uh glad for what I have in
FPU
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and you know Christmas uh
have youall started shopping yet John
yes we have you have yes well good for
you but we're doing we're doing it
different this year this year um we're
not going to buy a thousand things okay
we're going to do a couple things and be
very intentional yes with it and so yeah
we're already thinking that through so
nice so well we know that Christmas is a
big deal to all of you watching and
listening and if you're a fan of the
show and fan of this content and you
want to give out some things that have
to do with whether it's your mental
health your career your money there's a
lot of meaningful gifts for Christmas
during our $12 sale so shop our
bestselling books a Total Money Makeover
baby steps Millionaires and own your
past change your future for just
$12 and also uh John's questions for
humans Christmas edition is back and all
those conversations cards are as low as
$10 right now and these sold out last
year the Christmas ones were gone so we
got more we're ready to go ready to go
so make sure you guys to check all of
that out at ramsy solutions.com store
the $12 sale is there for you so order
the books order the stuff to give away
to your friends and family and actually
let it be a meaningful gift you know
that you give that's actually going to
help them in their life so Ramy
solutions.com store all right up next we
have Logan here in Nashville hey Logan
welcome to the show
hi Rachel how are you we are doing well
how can we
help yeah I wish I was better than I
deserved a what's up sorry Logan what's
going on I'm just kidding okay um um
anyway um So
currently um I do have uh some dad I got
to deal with um and I never thought I
would actually be calling into the
show um after all these years but um So
currently I do have some uh credit card
debt um I have a little bit student
loans left I am married my wife has a
little bit student loan debt too but
basically this year we've had a we've
had a lot of trouble with cash flow um
her um her jobs not you know just
basically paying her by check she was
working remotely and things kind of fell
behind and um you feeling the stress
we're yeah we are feeling the stress um
and we actually and our and I mean this
lightly cuz um our marriage did kind of
uh was a little bit on the Rocks but you
know we both want to make things work
out so I guess the best way to go
forward about this because I mean I know
I got a little bit of I probably got a
few years as far as an uphill battle as
far as debt yeah um the snowball de and
everything but how can I get
her um on board with with this without
feel with you know on the same page as
me uh without feeling you know so
anxious and everything and
um basically I suggest my question yeah
okay so just a couple of just tactical
questions Logan how much do you guys
make a
year um so I make around 48 on one job
uh I am taking I am taking a second
part-time job
so um and she makes around 38 okay
all right so and then um before taxes
before taxes sure and then how much debt
is how much debt are we talking how much
student loan debt combined and credit
cards
combined uh so my student loan is 6,000
um which is not bad I mean it's just I
haven't paid it in a couple years mainly
because well we won't get into it you
have to
yeah yeah but then how much
ISS uh hers is around 17
okay how much credit cards you guys
have uh 13 uh that's over two cards one
is uh one is approaching the max out and
the the culprit of it
is uh you know our rent $1,700 a month
right now and uh there were time hold on
hold on hold on hold on Logan Lan Logan
not the culprit not the
culprit I'm listening to you talk and
you have very distant language from
reality here's what I mean by that we
had some trouble with cash flow no y'all
didn't make enough money and you spent
too
much the main culprit is the rent it's
not it's not the main culprit is we have
chosen to make 38 and 48 and not work
one job two job three jobs we've chosen
to live in a city I all of the healing
that has to happen in this household is
going to start with y'all both choosing
reality
right and not living in this this world
is descending Upon Us in all these ways
no dude we're going to take it right by
the horns and say what is real and what
is not what is real is we are broke what
is real is dude you don't have a ton of
debt you have too much but I thought you
were going to say
$150,000 the way you're just sounding
like Eeyore like oh well it's all coming
down bro it's not you know what I mean
it feels like by my standards because
this wasn't a problem to you years ago
and I mean yeah but you stop being
intentional yeah exactly that's
it yeah why'd you sty being
intentional um I don't know I'm just
thinking about like why just be just
give me a straight right on answer why
did you stop being
intentional I guess it's because I cared
too much because the thing is this was a
this was a philosophy you know Dave's
philosophy was something something that
was important to me and then I found
myself in this position but I guess what
I didn't do was make sure that I did the
necessarily necessary things to keep us
out of this
position um perfect that's the kind of
ownership you need moving forward
because now you're going to right yeah
yes okay what and what's your wife's
hesitation because I know you were
asking about the marriage part of that
what is her why is she why is she
hesitant well she's never
[Music]
really I see best way to put this um
just say it just say it just say
it she's not she's never really focused
on this aspect of life just okay so
she's a free spirit she's a spender she
doesn't really want to be bogged down
with the
details right at at least she used to be
worse um but obviously this past couple
years she's saying okay we need to do
something yeah yeah Logan there's a
there's a feeling I'm having and I could
be totally off Bas because even the way
you're talking about the marriage your
marriage and then the money stuff
there's just a level of kind of like
life is just happening to us and kind of
a level of
apathy that starts to kind of just sink
in and you kind of just become going
with the flow and there's not this and
I'm not saying you have to live your
entire life intense 24/7 but realizing
that people that win in life that have a
healthy marriage doesn't just happen
right they work on it they go to therapy
they read books they sit down with
couples that have a marriage that they
want they they practice communication
they they fight about I mean like they
they do the work with money people that
win with money it doesn't just happen
like they are so focused so intentional
right so there's there's this level of
intensity I kind of just like want to
shoot through the air right now to you
and your wife to be like you guys can do
this like your numbers and especially if
you get a second job like you guys can
make real progress but you have to care
like you have to get in this place and I
think you may be there where you're
realizing oh my gosh I don't know where
else to go that's why you're calling us
but there's this um this intensity that
I want you guys to have that's going to
help you get through this process this
lack
aial kind of attitude it kind of just
you you kind of end up getting what
you're getting and that's and nothing
changes there has to be some level of
deep change for you guys and there's a
level of passion there for life for your
marriage for your money like all of this
to do it on purpose right and and I
would want you and your wife to be on
that same page and working towards that
same value system that same goal this
sounds like I'm going to come out of
left field do you exercise
dude um I do every day I'm a delivery
driver so it feels like
it like what do you get passionate
about um well honestly about music
because I am a musician and that's why I
came to Nashville and I actually uh I
actually made a living as a
self-employed musician for years when
the pandemic happened and I kind of went
in other directions okay but I still
play well I want you to deal with the
loss of that of that identity that who
you are and that I'm I'm guessing Rachel
there is a sense of just kind of lost at
sea and good for you I know some
musicians who just sit on their hands
good for you for getting out there and
throwing boxes to put food on your table
that's amazing but I want you to find
some Vigor again like Rachel said like
find some passion some intensity sit
down with your wife and hold both of her
hands and say let's do this you can do
[Music]
[Applause]
it hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to church Hill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
so John inevitably what money brings up
at times for people in their
relationships are just these like little
awkward moments you know I know you and
I things come up you and I have have
talked to couples who are like um seeing
each other naked made kids um bought
homes
together don't know how to talk about
money and they're like uh I don't want
to bring it up it's like y'all made a
human like I know but it's weird right
totally it's a thing and with them
friends and family and in-laws and
parents I mean all of it how about
jamaan over there deloney like so like
really so go Bing right had these
awkward questions and and George
Campbell and I on the Happy on Smart
money happy hour we've talked a lot we
we've had this conversation because
there's so many that come up in life and
I don't feel as awkward just because I
guess I we just talk about money every
day it's our job so I'm like I don't
even think twice about it um but for so
many people it it it is such a thing so
let me tell you a quick deloney thing
about awkward can I do this James so um
I was creating a questions for humans
sex and intimacy thing we're working
through
and some people in the building were
like John this is super awkward super
awkward and I was like I asked these
questions to my friends so I went home
to Sheila my wife and I was like hey
these are all questions like I've asked
at dinner parties across and she goes
and I quote Yeah John you've been making
dinner awkward for a long time and I
didn't know I was like oh gez okay all
right so anyway I know you're very
comfortable with all these questions
about okay but we get so so James split
these questions up and so I don't know
what Rachel's about to ask me and she
doesn't know what I'm about to ask her
so you go first cuz mine starts with
number two okay so I'm goingon to I'm
going to um put it in as if I'm asking
you okay awkward money questions so John
uh how much money did you make last
year we did
good we we we were blessed last year
well I feel like it's a fair
conversation people are talking about
their income a lot and it's just it's
it's kind of a little selfish to hold it
all in because if I know what you're
making then maybe it's going to help me
so how it would but like one of the most
common things people tell me is I'm
selfish with private things and like
you're exactly right I like to keep that
between me and my wife I tried to really
go in there okay so if someone because
that's a trend right now oh to ask how
much oh yeah oh Jin Z's like all in it
and because they're like yeah if my
friend's in marketing and I'm in
marketing I should know what she makes
but you I because because if she's
making more than me I could then I have
the potential to make more I just don't
know I could be making more if I don't
know what everyone else is making see
here's my challenge with that here's oh
my gosh here's my challenge with that it
goes back to the book you just wrote if
me and my leader Jeremy Breeland we
shook hands yeah here's what I'm here's
what I agree
to it doesn't matter at all what you
make because I agreed to this I shook
hands the only time it's unethical I
think is if we agree and shake hands and
we say on X dollar amount and he pays me
Y and he pays me less and I'm like hey
we agreed on this that's but that's
talking about within your leader your
person that's paying you I'm about your
friend or this does say colleague oh
this does say colleague oh yeah but hey
if I knew how much you made John person
board so you know exactly what I make so
there you go okay number two all right
number two you're asked to donate to
charity but don't want to okay so hey
Rachel youate at the grocery store all
the time will you donate no no no no
round up not not the school stuff I'm
your friend and we work together would
you donate to my pet parent
fund to help pet parents particularly
cat moms and dog dads all across the
United States would you donate to that
charity is it a
501c3 it it could be okay it's an 812
well Wednesday night we actually planned
out all of our giving oh so you
instantly went to blame the husband that
was well played Winston and I I said
both of us we are
one in this we have planned out our
giving for the year so we give to three
organizations so that's already planned
out and we kind of have a miscellaneous
giving so let me chat with him but we
usually put we usually give to
individuals in that fund so um you can
apply next year to the Winston giving
wow I'm just kidding can imagine like a
a Girl Scout coming to your door with
Girl Scout cookies be like oh here's an
application you can apply for next year
I did buy wreaths from a Boy Scout last
week because I wanted to support the
scouts and I buy Girl Scout Cookies By
The Wagon load so there you go Ben Min
okay next one um hey John can I I can I
borrow some money no what do you need
I'll give it to you but I'm not going to
loan it to you I just don't loan money
yeah cuz it makes I feel weird I I can
pay it back in six months but that's
cool if I feel like I can give it to you
I'll just yeah I won't take it back all
right that's how you handle that one
people just give it's a gift never hey
um Rachel I borrowed $500 and I didn't
pay you back I'm sorry I forgot to pay
back that's fine I gave it to you oh you
just switched it I don't loan M cuz
originally you loan but okay cool wait
is that your number four yeah someone
forgot to pay you back
oh okay wait okay okay hold on uh how
much 500 like for pling like say like we
were all going on like a couple's trip
and I like yeah I didn't have it well is
it if you don't have it or you have it
and you just forgot to pay me back cuz I
have forgetful friends in my life and
they're like oh I meant to vinmo you I
just got that text this morning yeah I
forget all the time yeah so if it's like
you have the money it's like oh we
forgot to pay you and want back for the
plane tickets that's fine you can just
spend M me today no worries yeah yeah if
your friend don't have the money then
forget it I I'm not holding that over
you okay um okay so we're out at a uh on
a double date and you leave the waiter
$10 on a nice meal not a great Tipp or
what do you do this reminds me of a
Friends episode for Rachel Green's dad
anyone didn't tip well and Ross swooped
in there and change the tip oh dude I'm
I'll make a big ordeal that wait to your
friends yeah I will even if it's not a
great
friends if it's not a great friend if I
don't know him that well you don't know
him that well I'll over tip no but what
if they what if they bought the meal and
there's one bill sitting on the counter
or sitting on the table I've actually
I've actually left money before just
left some cash what if you don't have
cash change it would you could do that I
don't do that to money you can't do that
yeah not good um you're on a
date and they ask about how much money
you make I'm a date you and this instant
thing just didn't work out and so you're
on a date with Dan and Dan's like Rachel
H how much money do you make how many
dates has it been three yeah no sorry
you don't get that no if we're like if
we're about to be if we're about to like
oh yeah I'm in love he's in love and we
are and this is it then we're talking
money plan it for like next stages yeah
yeah yeah yeah then then then then I
share so would you want it to be a third
a surprise would I W want to be not a
surprise but like
um Dave tells a story
of like you you all and your spouses
knew that Dave and Shar were doing good
but didn't know like oh wow and so I
would imagine I would have liked that
conversation to be had after I was
married so there wasn't this I would
always be able to know I'm not some
somebody isn't looking over my shoulder
or I'm not a part of a bigger plan this
person has they love me for me oh I hear
what you're saying driving an 88 cell
easy hatchback cuz I knew my wife loved
me not for anything not after the money
yeah no I could see that
totally you have a roommate yeah uh and
he's not paying his fair
share uh you have to have that hard
conversation yeah you agreed to rent you
agreed to pay rent bro if you don't yeah
and here's the thing bro people always
say I don't want to screw this up like I
don't want to make the relationship all
weird they did all you're doing is
addressing weirdness that they have made
they have violated your friendship it's
not you that's a good point and they'll
often go Are you seriously going to just
like throw me out I'm simply responding
to your lack of character and your
violation of our friendship you did it I
just got to call spade a spade I can't
afford all this rent I got to go get
another roommate now who will actually
pay rent are you serious does that make
sense it's hard that's a great point is
calling it out yes I've never thought
about that you haven't done anything
wrong right I had a group of friends in
in in college and we may or may not have
gotten in trouble and it was fascinating
cuz every person in line was no that was
it was me next person a dude that was me
and the person eventually it was like
y'all get out right yep it wasn't the if
you tell on me cuz that makes me a bad
friend for letting you go down for me
right so I think we get that out of
order all the time um hey you can't
afford to be a part of someone's bridal
party I want you to be in my wedding but
it's $7,000 fly to alapo
all these all these destinations yeah uh
man I will be there in attendance I just
we I can't I I don't have money to be
able to do it I would just say it I
would just say it yeah y'all if money
wasn't awkward I don't know I don't know
if it still is I feel like we really
helped a lot of
people a lot of people out with that
segment embrace the awkwardness people
embrace it head into it this is the
ramsy
show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsay show it is a
free call anywhere in the country at AA
8255 225 up next we have Ashton in
Panama City Beach Florida hey Panama hey
Ashton hey you live in a great area from
you oh you know it is beautiful the
Emerald Coast it is a lot of nashille
people head your way on most breaks
school breaks Yes Man in one month me
and my wife may drive up to Franklin to
see you folks come on I hope you do come
join us we have some lovely people right
now in the lobby watching the show we
have lots of visitors a lot so hell much
said hi I will Ashton says Hi everyone
Ashton says hi how can we
help yes so me and my wife we are
blessed beyond measure we are Jin zers
to kind of follow and piggyback off what
what you just said and we talk about
money all the time we communicate and we
are blessed because we're in baby step
3B now however um we're really just in a
place where we really don't know what to
do with our money um because we are
having to travel four different
locations in a matter of nine months for
her doctor physical therapy school and
so we're in the second rotation now and
we have a fully funded emergency fund no
student loan debt no no Consumer Debt
whatsoever good for you guys don't oh
yes ma'am yes Blessed Like I said um but
however I just really want to make sure
we do things properly I don't want to
make any mistakes however I know life's
all about making mistakes right yeah no
DET as much as possible yes okay so um
so if you guys are past baby step three
are you guys
homeowners we are not homeor and that's
kind of where I was getting at is like
we're having to bounce around to these
different cities so we were in for the
first one now we're here in Florida and
the next third and fourth one's going to
be in Missouri so we really just don't
know where we're going to end up and I
don't necessarily know if we're even
going to be looking to buy a home soon
based on where we're going to live if
that makes sense for sure so you know
what I would do Ashton I would um be
funding retirement are you guys putting
any money
away you know that's the thing is like
we call this storm mode just cuz we're
our life's pretty chaotic right now and
nine months we have to really live out
of our suitcases and Airbnb cash flow
everything like that and so it's really
hard to like really get the budget down
when it comes to knowing what's GNA what
the months are going to look like in the
next months we're really just saving
everything that we have in order to be
able to cash flow it's a unique
situation and that's fair and nine
months for retiring isn't going to be
absolutely detrimental but I also don't
want to for that to be on pause for too
long right so so I if I were you guys I
would map out I would map out as much as
I could the next three moves and the
next nine months and just to say okay on
average how much is the Airbnb going to
be in Missouri is it if we're going to
be there for six months is it cheaper to
rent somewhere for a six-month rent or
Airbnb like I would I would kind of
start pricing out your options just to
get a ballpark because here's what I
don't want to happen Ashton I don't know
this may not be your case but I don't
want everything you know in those nine
months to cost you guys you know I'm
just going to throw out random numbers
20 grand and you guys have 50 saved and
you could actually be putting some of
that in the market because you have
plenty of of margin so so you are
telling me though that you feel like
there's not a ton of margin you're not
just being overly cautious you guys are
really like hey this money we we really
need and we'll probably
use just just based on living off of my
income to kind of give you an idea my
wife's full-time clinical so she's
putting in 40 hours no pay because it's
called education with quotations right
yeah what a racket right exactly exactly
you know Dr John deloney the higher
education thing I understand um so yeah
we're blessed beyond measure however
we're making about 50,000 but praise God
we've only spent 37,000 in a year and so
we're definitely living below what we're
making we're not making a ton okay that
makes sense yeah yes ma'am for sure so
yeah so I mean I would be fine with that
kind of storm mode mentality having
things in a in a high yield savings
account and just kind of staying afloat
until the 9 months but at 9 months uh do
you guys know where you're going to land
do you think you know what city you guys
will be at long term or no it's okay if
the answer is no I'm just curious that's
the kicker because she's Native American
and that's why she's getting a full ride
scholarship for grad school contract
though she has to go work for a clinical
or hospital that's under the Indian
Health Service Y and so that is such a
blessing knowing that she'll have to get
a job if doesn't get a job within 90
days they're just going to place a
randomly so it's a lot of stress you
know okay yeah hey so a I want to throw
something at you could be oh what's that
sir I'm gonna throw something at you so
there's a strange thing that happens um
when your the nerd word is agency okay
or autonomy but when your body
understands that somebody else is
directing your
life it will
sound the anxiet alarms it will make you
uncomfortable and most of us when we
start feeling that discomfort we start
trying to solve
problems that are just over the
hill right does that make
sense it sure does and part of me feels
like you are stretching because
comforable though right well part of me
thinks I mean you've got the plan Rachel
just laid it out to you just dump money
into an HSA a high yield savings account
not HSA but a high yield savings account
and focus on living every day the best
you can for the next nine months and
then where y'all get because I think a
lot of this is just spun up energy that
you're trying to dissipate by extra
extra extra
planning 100% I'm such a typ a planner
the nerd I got my every dollar inside
spreadsheet so dude homie listen get
into working out get into hiking get
into doing something else fish I'll tell
you that do what I do love the golfing
fish I'm trying to go golf with Ken one
day yeah don't for the sake of humanity
don't golf but go fishing go fishing but
like come up with some things you can do
in real time to practice dissipating
that anxiousness cuz what here's what's
going to happen you're going to start
attacking your wife with spreadsheets
and plans and she's going to come home
exhausted from a clinical rotation
you're going to be like hey honey I got
four new houses for the next seven moves
for the and she's going to start leaning
a little away from you cuz you'll be a
lot and what you're going to be doing is
using her to try to dissipate some of
your
anxiousness don't do that find Outlets
you have a deadline right Rachel like
there's an end of this Marathon y' just
in mile 12 and mile 12 to Mile 19 of a
marathon is the worst except for the
last five miles so just keep running
just keep running man and just I mean
you're kind of saying it even with
picking up Hobby like go do something
but also just take a breath too right so
like you guys are you're doing great
right if you guys were
you know deep into student loan debt and
she's getting her graduate and it's
going to be another 100 Grand you know
all of it then I could see the you know
the the tight woundedness that you are
ashon I feel like a little bit from the
call so breathe you have permission just
relax just breathe you're good that song
you're good just Faith Hill I think
Faith Hill oh yeah I don't know why
Jessica Simpson came to my head why did
that happen sorry Faith you're thinking
of Michelle Branch song also called
breathe oh lots of breathe okay listen
all Simpson start a start a playlist
Ashton with all of these songs remind
you to breathe because you've done the
hard work you guys are you're you're
young you don't have debt you have a
fully funded emergency fund plus the
storm mode that you're talking about so
all of it's good and then where you guys
land in nine months rent somewhere for a
year and kind of see okay is this going
to be a long-term play and if it is then
you can use some of that money that you
guys have saved in this period of time
for a down payment move forward but um
but I would not keep investing off the
table for for a year okay so like I
understand you know having some money
during all these transitions but once
you guys are settled in a place longer
than three months start thinking about
retirement and start working through the
baby steps because again the it's the
analysis or paralysis of the analysis is
what what it is yeah and it's also an
obsession with the finish line and the
more you can realize that finish line is
just going to move on you because the
moment you get assigned to um a Native
American Hospital you're going to want
to know how many years do we have to
what's the minimum number of years we
have to do this so that we can go to the
next place and you're going to
immediately jump to that and then as
soon as you move there you're going to
start looking for hey can we make more
money and you're going to realize as you
get older that finish line just keeps
moving so my buddy s the Stephano says
the man who falls in love with the
journey goes much further than the man
obsessed with the finish line so make
peace you're on an adventure for the
next decade of your life cuz you married
this amazing brilliant woman who's going
to be serving these special communities
awesome make peace with where you are
every step of the way not this obsession
with where you're going to end up that's
right Ashton thanks for the call thank
you America for listening thanks to all
the guys in the booth to make it happen
thank you John deloney for co-hosting
this hour this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
live hi from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John delone and it is a flee call
anywhere in the country at 8 at8 825
5225 answering your questions about life
money relationships and work so first up
we're going to go to hold on it's it's
launch day are we doing this again okay
fine it's launch day it is launch day I
will sell your book for you cuz it's
amazing I'm glad for what I have my new
kids book is out you guys I thought you
were just being weird all on yes it's
the name of the book it's so good oh I'm
not just saying I'm glad I am glad for
what I have you should be cuz I am it's
good but the book is amazing it's
beautiful and it's well done your
drawings are so good thank you I did not
draw them Lauren gaos I'll give you a
shout out but yes the illustrations are
precious so if you have kids in your
life you know kids you have kids this is
a great book especially for this time of
year because it's all about contentment
and learning that what we have uh is not
going to fulfill us long term and as
adults need that message too can I can I
say this yes um this doesn't get enough
publicity one of the last time I looked
I think it was number one but I don't
want to I don't want to be that strong
on it because I haven't looked at the
literature in a couple years one of the
very tiptop things when they distill
down what what can a parent do to help
your child be successful one of the
tiptop things read to them is not get
them into a fancy school not to it is to
read to them every day yes get
children's books and read to your child
every single day 10 minutes 30 minutes
read your child read your child read
your child and it changes her mind and
Rachel this is an awesome book to start
that for families who don't read this is
a great way to start that's right and
it's short so you're welcome parents
you're are welcome and it's my reading
level which makes me happy it has
rhyming words for
job all right we're go to the
and first up we have Judy and Raley hi
Judy welcome to the
show hi Rachel hi John thanks for having
me on absolutely how can we help well
I've been specifically waiting for John
on this one oh John here you go PES to
you so um my husband and I so I'm like
the budgeter and in charge of the
finances I pay all the bills out of our
joint account all that I've been
listening to Ramsey for years I'm super
no debt all of that kind of stuff um we
did have some debt we paid down to $600
almost done but then uh within the last
month I found out that my husband has
actually committed what the term is uh
it's Financial
infidelity um to to the tune of
$50,000 oh wow um I'm sorry
j yeah um the reason I'm not um like in
tears is because I've already done all
that um and I so what happened was um I
found out we have meetings about
and um I recently heard some advice that
instead of just having meetings we
should press I should press to see all
of the accounts like what are the
statements let me see the you know show
me your phone all that kind of thing and
he had been avoiding that and now I know
it's because um there were balances that
I did not know about um so what was what
was he spending that money on hun so I I
now have the pass codes to All to
everything and it was it was just
groceries and gas and kids need this it
was there was nothing extravagant it's
just he was spending more than he was
making and his s I'm stay home mom so we
just didn't have the income so he had
run up credit cards got a $7,000
personal loan to pay them off last year
and then ran them up ran it up again to
$24,000 another
$24,000 loan this year uh just two
months ago Judy have you seen those
statements yes I've seen everything now
I've seen I I got his credit report um
I've got um we have we have this The
Joint banking account but we each have a
checking um so I I have his lo I have
his passwords I have everything well I
here's what I'm here's what I'm getting
at it's very it happens it there's no
question happens yeah
$50,000 is a lot of money yeah to hide
it's a lot yeah and it's very rare that
the nickel and diming of groceries here
soccer uniform
here it doesn't include a hotel room
here a trip away here alcohol gambling
over here I've pulled every single
statement okay and he's he's so the
largest things are he's $250 he's loan
to his sister or you know something like
that there's nothing I've asked him down
to $60 $25 there's a $10 charge what is
this there's interest there's late fees
he hasn't been paying them on time so
there's hundreds of dollars of interest
and late fees um on on all of the cards
and I think what what Hur HS me the most
is that he I'm always talking about
money and I thought we were together um
but we were not and he he his
explanation is that well he doesn't
really have an explanation he's very
humble he told me he's ashamed he told
me he's embarrassed right he's sorry um
he feels like he wasn't able to provide
for us there really isn't anything I
like I said I've combed through I've
printed statements I've highlighted I've
asked about everything I've added things
up okay and he just was swiping his card
he just we just didn't have the money
okay so I I'm I we have we start FP
today because I I push for that okay
because you know mindset wise I feel
like we're just not we weren't together
so what's your question H how can I help
well something must have happened for
this connection like what what do I do
emotionally towards him I know there's
the money part but there's also the
relationship part sure so here's what's
here's what's real important you
mentioned it you kind of flew over it
and I think this is where you have to
start okay and this is not a traditional
infidelity
advice when somebody cheats on you
whether with another person whether with
money whether with any number of things
I think you can cheat on your wife with
a golf course think you cheat on your
wife with work right with the office I
think you can cheat on your wife with a
whole bunch of stuff or cheat on your
husband with a whole bunch of stuff I
think um honestly we so narrowly Define
fidelity into the act of some sort of
sexual act I think infidelity is way
bigger than that
but we often focus on that thing and
that's what the Hollywood movies are
made of and that's what the big oh my
gosh and you talk to your friends I
think there's another thing that is more
um catastrophic and that is
this you missed
it and you don't trust you
anymore you don't trust the ground you
walk on you don't trust the cereal
you're eating you don't don't trust your
own your own radar
system and that I think is often as much
if not more disorienting than the actual
Act of infidelity because when he sat
down and explained it to you and you
went through every single thing his
story actually makes
sense he was a grown man who was ashamed
that he couldn't provide for his kids
and he just punted reality until it hit
him in the mouth I wouldn't advise that
but that story is
plausible what's scary for you is the
sidewalk you walk on which is I can at
least trust me you don't trust you
anymore and so I think you start this
process a with here's the four or five
things I need on a daily basis so that I
can begin to rebuild trust your marriage
as you knew it was over y'all are
building something completely new honey
I need these four or five things every
single day and you get to decide what
those are and he gets to decide whether
he's in or out but more importantly I
want you to go talk to a professional
counselor in fact stay on the line I'm
going to hook you up with three months
with my friends at
betterhelp you have to start learning to
trust you again cuz you're not crazy and
right now you feel like you've lost in
the wind hang on we'll get you hooked up
with some professional licensed
[Music]
therapists
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped fam living
across all 50 states so see if chm could
be right for your family check out more
today at CH ministries.org
[Music]
budget
today's question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services here at Ramsey we believe and
making home ownership a blessing not a
burden so we recommend neighborly
Nationwide network of service
professionals to help repair maintain
and improve your home find the help that
you need at neighbor.com Ramsey today
all right today's question comes from
Daniel in Oregon I'm a 40-year-old
married man with three young children I
have an Ivy League degree in an MBA from
Georgetown I am buried in both mortgage
and non-mortgage debt my total
non-mortgage debt is
$476,000 my gosh and my house has both a
mortgage and a HELOC on it for a total
of $881,000 my total debt is 1.3 $3
million my wife doesn't work outside the
home and I work as a consultant my gross
annual income can range from 225,000 to
415,000 with commissions and Equity
payments I have no retirement savings no
life insurance no will and struggle
every month to pay my four walls all my
credit cards are maxed out I need
help oh my
gosh Daniel um
well before we like dive into the
numbers of this specific scenario this
is the classic example you guys of your
money it's it's 80% Behavior it's only
20% head knowledge you can know what to
do but if you choose to live above your
means even with a close to half a
million dollar annual income this is the
result you get like you could outspend
yourself continually you can continue to
do this so my first
piece of advice D to Daniel is you have
to fix you stop spining you have to
understand why what what is all of this
what's the mindset that you guys are in
what are you what are you you know it's
it's almost like this I don't know if
it's the comparison keeping up game if
it's the if it's like a medicated you
know it's like a medicator just to go
and spend and to get like whatever the
thing is that's causing these massive
numbers and this massive stuff of of
$476,000 which I know is part education
but also lifestyle you guys have to you
have to look in the mirror and ask some
serious questions about who I am and
what am I doing that got me to this
place
so understanding you Daniel is like it's
a big part of this but on a quick note I
mean I John I may at this point just
sell the house like well he's got to pay
the helck off on it first there's a
point that like oh the HELOC of oh of
880 it's a total between the mortgage
and the heok I I
would
I would probably Sprint to try to pay
the HELOC off as fast as I could and by
the way wife goes back to work sorry but
yeah y'all are y'all are not broke y'all
are desperate scary broke um wife goes
back to work and um we pay this heck off
and we sell the house yeah because we
got to go back to square one and here's
what I was going to say
earlier my dad had a bachelor's degree
from the University of Houston and was a
homicide detective made made x amount of
money and Mom stayed home my wife got a
PhD and got a research professorship I
got a PhD and did all that and what that
gave us because we didn't practice the
tools we didn't use the tools all it did
was gave us a shiny object in front of
the bank's eyes to dig a massive hole
that my dad could have never dug himself
cuz the banks would have let him right
so sometimes this fancy ivy league
degree and your fanc NBA and your fancy
job
doing um I don't want to say charlton's
work but yeah doing consultant work
without some skin in the
game it just simply allows you to dig
yourself a $1.4 million
hole and if the math is math they're
going be there that's right that's right
yep now here's the other side of it um I
do want to hold this Dave taught me this
about ratios if you're making three to
$400,000 a year
um you can't pay this off you have to
make some drastic changes sell the cars
get a pay off the heck sell your home um
begin working this debt snowball down
well I've got kids I don't care you have
a two-bedroom apartment now but I make
it I don't care right this is not the
picture you had in your head with your
IV League degree and your fancy NBA you
got to deal with math yeah and this
whole thing too when you're looking at
it I'm like this is what the world says
is going to create create peace and
happiness for you it's just get stuff
get stuff get the he I don't know if you
use the helck to do Renovations on a
brand new I don't know what what what
all this was used for but like this is
the that's like that's like that's
normal this is the normal plan that's
supposed to get you some life of
happiness and fulfillment and fun and
peace and Jewel all this stuff and you
realize it just because of the Avenue of
debt it just digs you down where you get
the opposite effect you're making an
incredible income and all this stuff was
supposed to be this like oh exciting
thing in life and it ends up absolutely
crushing your soul so it is a it's a
hard lesson to learn Daniel but I think
that you guys have a couple of years of
really really hard sacrifice of from
both you and your wife and and you and
it's worth it you're going to choose
your heart it's either going to be hard
for a few years of sacrifice and maybe
her going to a job she hates but it pays
good I mean whatever you guys have to
do that I would rather have that hard
and then have freedom on the other side
than than to live in this day in and day
out and nothing changing so I want to
look forward to being 46 years old I
would love for you to put down on paper
I'm
46y old married man with three kids I
want you to rewrite this I'm a 46y old
married man with three kids I have an
Ivy League degree in NBA from
Georgetown and then you get to write
what happens next yeah you could still
be buried in mortgage and non-mortgage
debt and still floating all this garbage
or you can have made some drastic
Lifestyle Changes stopped spending sold
the cars all of them got out of the
lease for your rent your summer home or
whatever sold the furniture sold the
stuff pay off the helck sell the house
and Sprint over the next five years
towards peace yeah and live like you're
making 75 a year if that you know like
yeah I mean just we're going SC SC it's
nothing it's nothing and you can climb
out of these numbers that's the great
thing with an income like this I mean
you could have $350,000 a year freed up
to or more to to go and throw at this
debt right like I like there's there's a
big shovel which is positive thing by
way uh income can range from 225 to 415
I call bull crap on that it's going to
be
415 and your job is not to go oh man
well I missed the account it's to get on
the phone for the next 72 hours and find
another one right there is no well some
years is good and some
that you're not a farmer and you're not
praying to God for rain you are able to
go out and make this stuff work go
figure that out yep absolutely so John
one of the um groups of people that I I
personally really respect and love uh in
our country are veterans and so in honor
of Veterans Day we're going to be giving
away Financial Peace University which is
our nine lesson course when it comes to
money to 10,000 veterans totally for
free now through Monday no November 13th
so FPU is one of these things that we
have helped I mean millions of people
over 10 million people walk through and
understand the basics when it comes to
handling money so whether it's Daniel's
question we just went over or even
callers that we've had uh in in this
show today you there's there's these
basic principles that are really key
it's it's a small part of the puzzle but
actually changing the behavior and
knowing what to do with your money and
then doing it that's where you start to
see progress and that's what FPU is so
great at it puts you in a community you
start to practice these new habits
around money this new way of thinking
and we really walk with you through it
so if you are a veteran and you want to
take FPU for free go to Ramsey
solutions.com veterans and fill out the
simple form that we have there and help
us get the word out by sharing the link
to all the veterans that you know so
again Ramy solutions.com veterans over
10,000 veterans were giving FPU away for
free so make sure to check that out but
yeah I love that I love that love that
love that love that yeah that's a this
is a it's a hard topic you guys money
and even coming off Daniel's question in
this like it's a lot and you can have
all smarts in the world and struggle
with making a budget it just is man with
the basic stuff and so have the humility
to say hey what I'm doing isn't working
so I'm going to change it and hopefully
you for all those you listening if you
haven't done it yet sign up um because
it will help you create new habits this
is the Ramy
show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netu was the
software we used to optimize and take us
to the next level netsuite gave us the
visibil into all of our numbers so that
we could communicate across departments
and plan ahead better and as we grew it
scaled with us net week worked for ramsy
and it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34,000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John delone and we are taking your calls
it's a free call anywhere in the country
atle 88255 225 up next we have Dylan in
Indianapolis hey Dylan welcome to the
show hey guys thanks for having me
absolutely how can we
help well um I'm 20 years old uh College
Dropout and I put myself and kind of of
I would say a decent amount of debt a 20
which I'm not very proud of I owe about
70k in loans and I'm just I mean I
stress every day about it when I wake up
so I'm just trying to see you guys' view
on how I should start attacking my loan
okay and how I can pay off my debt okay
what's the debt
in well um I have 32k in a one semester
of student
loans and then I have wait wait one
semester where'd you go to school on
Mars
I went to a private Christian School in
uh Minneapolis but one semester was
$32,000 yes
sir so their total annual is 64 Grand
per year oh my God yes okay that's okay
Dylan that's okay we're gonna keep
moving We're Gonna Keep On Moving what
else what else you got it's already
happens um I'm not very proud of this
one but I actually 36k on a carw okay we
can get rid of that that's okay what
else and then I have a personal one for
like
3700 okay what was that
for um well basically when I dropped out
of college um I start I bought I got a
job in car sales and I needed a place to
live in Minneapolis that was like in a
safe area and that's how much the market
rent was 1570 and then I had some income
problems of that job so I moved to
Indianapolis with my roommate and I had
to buy all my leaves okay
uh so what are you doing now for
work um I still do Car Sales okay and
how much are you
making um making less than what I owe
monthly yeah because of uh interest
rates are tough right now
right well I I was blessed to have a
good interest rate on my uh loans my uh
no no no I'm saying people aren't buying
cars right
now um well I mean kind of Hit or Miss
to be honest how much will you make this
year how much will you how much will you
make this year
my base salary is 24,000 and I make
maybe a th a month in
commission okay you quit that job
tomorrow you're not making enough money
yeah you're making 36 you could I
literally took my son to breakfast the
other day and I drove past a sign it was
my daughter drove p a sign and it said
McDonald's starting $20 an hour your car
salesman Days Are Over you're not good
at that you've done it two different
places and you don't make enough money
to eat you got to let that dream
go all right
and you got to work at McDonald's all
day and then deliver pizzas at night and
drive Uber into the morning like you're
broke broke broke broke is that fair how
much how much do you how much would the
car sell for
Dylan um well I had some negative equity
in my last car so I kind of carried over
to the new loan when I bought this car
how much okay um so the car is probably
worth about like 27 in the market right
now by 30 35 something okay
so uh yeah I mean I would
would I mean I I would I would take out
a loan of like 15 pay off the 36 get a
cheap car there's no way they give him
15 though you you do what I don't think
anybody's going to give him a loan for
15 I'll get the personal loan out could
you go could you go to a credit credit
union and get a loan for 15,000
bucks I mean i' barely get one by I
couldn't even get one for like the 3,000
about my dad cosigning yeah without the
coig I think there's no way well I'm
just figure out how to get cuz you your
car loan is what you make a
year yes' yeah so we got to figure out a
plan to get that to get that out of your
life um where's your
family uh my family lives in Michigan
okay is that a safe place for you to go
live for a
while I I would say so yes yeah because
here here's the deal you're going to
need some support around you Dylan in
your 20 okay so I want to give you some
Grace you're a kid I mean yeah yeah no
the mad at you he is that that the
systems that surround an 18 to 19
yearold allowed you a kid just trying to
do what everyone's telling you to do you
got to go get a nice car you got to get
a good sales job you got to go to this
college that cost
$34,000 or whatever it was a semester
you got to go do this stuff and you
can't afford it and they let you do that
and I I'm just sick to my stomach but
they let you do that man so Dylan what
the best thing that you can do right now
is your income that side of the equation
because you probably don't have many
expenses I'm I'm I'm assuming not you're
renting and you're going to be living on
nothing you're not going to have a life
and I would I would probably move close
to where you have a support system with
some family if nothing's keeping you in
Indianapolis uh I would consider that
but I would I Dylan I mean I would be
working 80 hours 80 hours a week I'd be
getting up and I'd be somewhere at 6:00
a.m. and I would be getting home at 9:00
p.m. I mean you're going to be exhausted
but Dylan you're 20 years old you can do
it you don't have you don't have kids at
home you don't have a wife I mean like
this is the season this is the season to
do it to absolutely go nuts because it's
the only part of the equation that's
actually going to give you some level of
grounding and hopefully after a year of
that ofing some level of income then
maybe you can get out of this car loan I
want this car loan out quickly uh
because it's not it's not worth it and
so whatever you have to do to be able to
say hey what can I do to qualify to sell
this and get it out because I think
that's going to that's the only piece of
this that's going to be able to relieve
some level of pressure that you can get
out so I would be I would be taking on
two to three jobs and again you're not
going to have a life Dylan but I think
that for a season you're going to be
able to to to to knock some of this out
because um and the other great thing
Dylan that just encourage you that
you're learning this at 20 years old
people call this show and they're 45
that have you know a situation like this
yeah no re so this is your moment Dylan
of saying like what I did isn't working
it's not working and so I will never
again find myself in this position if I
don't have the money I don't care if
it's for school I don't care if it's for
a car if I don't have the money I'm not
buying it like this needs to be a point
in your story Dylan that you look back
and you say at 20 years old I did some
dumb stuff took me a little bit to get
out of it some hard work but I got out
of it and and that was it that that's
the last time you know this cuz Dylan if
you get this all straightened up you're
at especially at your age like this is
where you're like I you could build some
serious wealth in the future but not
with these habits and not with this
mindset that you used to
have does that make sense if you were my
friend if you were my friend Dylan I
would tell you to see about having a
hard conversation with my mom and dad
and I say hard it probably be easy but
an embarrassing one and say I need to
move in for a year and I'm going to try
to make
$40,000 and if I have a year with no
bills and I make $40,000 and I take home
28 of that um I can start making a dent
in some of these
things yeah I currently live in my my
room man I pay about 400 a month for my
part of the rent and your water and your
electric and your
food yeah it's about five
525 for all of your bills plus
food uh not that's not including food I
pay about 60 bucks every two weeks for
food no way
yeah I'm I don't I don't eat a lot I'm
paying attention so you let's say you
have you say $700 total which I don't
fully believe but I'll give it to you um
and you make a th000 bucks a month at
your
job I make about 2,000 base salary and
about a th000 extra commission okay so
what's your take home every
month uh this month will be
2700 that's after taxes and
everything yeah okay are you able to pay
pay minimum payments on all of this are
you able to put a dent into the student
loan keep up with the car
payment yeah I actually have never
missed a payment yet but I'm getting to
the point now where like I feel like I
might miss a payment and I'm afraid
because my father co-signed most of
these loans and I don't want to ruin his
credit because I'm my poor yeah that's a
fair uh weight to carry for sure so yeah
Dylan I think life just looks really
different and I and I'm sorry for that
because I think there's maybe something
you had in your head of what this is
going to be and it's probably not for a
season and season like 3 or four years
well I was going to say and map out
Dylan that like the end game like like
look at all of your payments look at all
of this and what John saying even if you
go scorched Earth and you and you
literally don't pay for anything and you
say hey Mom and Dad for a year can I
live with you guys like start to map out
a plan to say okay it's going to take me
3 years and then that is that's able to
be sustainable if it's just this this
idea that I'm going to have to live like
this forever and ever it you can start
to be demotivated so have a game plan
map this out as more detailed as
possible and then don't go back in Dylan
don't go back
[Music]
in
[Applause]
[Music]
so Christmas is coming up you guys it is
quick and those of you Christmas
shopping uh if you think about a gift
that actually can can help your friends
and family make sure to check out our
$12 Christmas sales so our books Total
Money Makeover baby steps Millionaires
and own your past change your future all
for just
$1 and John's questions for human
conversation cards are as low as $10
right now hey let's do one with the
Christmas edition we have Thanksgiving
deck here too oh yes um here you
go what makes me and Jade did this one
the other day oh what makes your family
weird and what makes your family the
best what makes our family weird I don't
know if this would be weird we debate
all the time as you could probably
imagine I can imagine Ramsey I have to
imagine dinners and for the most part
this may be the weird part we can kind
of just walk away like Daniel and I
really got into it about aliens said
dinner the other night and we uh we said
all right cheers and cheers our
margaritas and walked away from it but
it got heated for a hot second but we
kind of can just like we were in moving
we were in a in a in a debate the other
night uh me and Daniel and a couple
others and Daniel's like all right guys
I'm going to head out and it was just so
perfect it was awesome oh my gosh so
yeah I would say that's uh that's it
that's what makes some great too I love
it Thanksgiving food item that makes you
gag
oh I'm not a green bean fan really so
green bean something of the other with
like the soup what's the filling soup
people use oh cream and mushroom soup
yeah no oh I like to put my face in that
I love
it no whatever you're like a health
person I know you shouldn't like those
soups I do chicken
now I don't like the um things they call
pink salad which is just like goo with
stuff haven't seen those though I feel
like those are just in the movies oh
they're they're not they're real bits of
ham and Cheerios and whatever else they
put in them oh my gosh it's so gross so
go to ramsy solutions.com store so you
buy something great and not a pink gooey
nasty thing and also make sure to check
out George camel's brand new book that's
coming out in January guys it's
pre-ordered today try it for there for
only $20 20 bucks it's so great and you
get uh $10 or $100 of free bonus items
that includes the ebook exclusive access
to Online private event Q&A with George
a lot of stuff you guys so George
exposes some of the most common money
myths and excuses head on and it's funny
we love George you're going to love him
too Breaking Free of broke make sure to
check that out so we got a lot of stuff
going on this season you guys a lot of
tools out there because we want to
continue this conversation to help you
guys when it comes to your money all
right up next we have Nathan in Fargo
hey Nathan welcome to the show hey how
you guys doing we're doing great how can
we
help uh I had quite a few questions it's
all kind of about the same thing though
I recently started a new job and uh it
doesn't pay too bad but I'm kind of at a
loss for what to do with my money I
would really like to be getting a house
in I don't know five six years and I'm
kind of just getting a wide array of
advice from parents from friends that do
investing uh I even went to some people
that do like you you pay someone else to
do investing for you and it's just hard
to take advice from anyone because my
parents they just say stick it in an
account and leave it my friends say do
stocks but they've been trained for that
yeah and then the investors I kind of
feel like they've got their own you know
their own agenda with the commission
that they're going to be getting from it
so it's just kind of hard to know what
to do yeah that's fair okay so how much
are you making a year uh so I'm based at
80,000 but I'm getting about 85 uh it's
just easy to get little bits of extra
money here and there okay perfect and do
you have any debt I owe my parents
$20,000 uh for school but there's no
interest on that okay and I'm paying
them back at about I about $500 a week
is what we agreed on okay uh do you have
any money
saved uh not much this is a pretty
recent job so I've got you know a couple
thousand in the bank account right now
and I've got a th000 in a Roth and then
a th in uh just some individual
individual money markets but that's
that's all that I've got how much are in
all of those just a couple hundred
dollar thousand in each okay so total
probably what $5,000 that you could get
to that doesn't include
girra uh yeah that's pretty pretty fair
okay perfect how old are you Nathan 21
okay awesome um yeah so what we walk
people through Nathan is a process
called the baby steps and it really is
the mo it's the it's not necessarily the
fastest but it's the most effective way
to get from point A to point B when it
comes to your money and to build wealth
that actually is lasting and sustainable
and it's not this flash in the pan of
this quick money so um so what I would
encourage you to do is I would I would
keep $1,000 in one of your money market
accounts I would cash everything out but
your Roth uh to throw at this 20 grand
and I would pay it off as quickly as
possible get it out of your even even if
there's no interest all of I would make
that my number one goal just go ahead
and get debt free because when you free
up that $500 a week which is incredible
I mean that's two grand a month that
that you then have to save more and save
up for an emergency fund three to six
months of expenses in that money market
account that you have with your $1,000
just add to that after you pay off this
debt and then I would look to invest in
retirement so you have your Roth open
which is awesome but I would put 15% of
my income yeah towards your Roth if you
if your job offers a 401k do that but
these retirement type accounts when you
get to that point uh it really is the
best way I know some of your friends
probably do some single stocks and kind
of play the market but honestly when you
look at day trading overall over a long
period of time you end up losing money
there's so much risk in it and you know
again people are trained in this and if
that's like how their mind works but
even those people that are trained in it
it usually comes out as a loss leader
and so being able to put your your money
in something that is reliable like good
mutual funds really is the best bet
Nathan and if you start this early it's
it's amazing what can happen if you go
to Ramsey solutions.com and look at our
investing calculator there and just play
with some numbers like it's just it it's
phenomenal starting at 21 at where
you're at I know you're not going to
start today because I want you to get
out of debt and get that emergency fund
but I mean that's that's where you're
heading which is amazing and so um yeah
I mean if you want to if you want to buy
a house too in the middle of that I
would do that save up a good down
payment even before you invest that
could be your next step but if you're
not in a rush for that if there's still
you know life is in limbo because of
season of life where you're at or age
you don't know where you're going to be
long term don't feel like you have to
rush into that sure okay and Nath well I
toally oh sorry to cut you off man you
are Super Wise I heard something in you
and I want you to never ever ever lose
this
okay okay you you have a $20,000
interest free loan to your
parents you know that they want to float
that because there's a little bit of
guilt a little bit of parent weirdness
there yeah yeah 100% you have a couple
of buddies you're like bro dude buy
stocks we're going to be billionaires
dude if we bought Tesla we and you
recognize dude I don't even like eat the
same food yall eat cuz you're morons and
then you have a couple other buddies
that don't have the heart of a teacher
they have the heart of a commission
salesman when it comes to uh retirement
bro you need to put it in my like super
fun and I'm and so you're like hey wait
a minute you just make money every time
I do this you are so wise looking like
following the rabbit down the hole and
so what Rachel just gave you was a map
to unhooking yourself from all these
other opinions and living a life that
very very very few Americans live which
is a life of freedom and peace
that sounds pretty good like Mom like oh
honey you don't need to pay us back this
much Mom I'm not going to owe anybody
any money including you well it's no
interest I know Mom now yeah dude and it
just changes it changes Christmas right
yeah no 100% you know if they see me you
know showing up and I've got you know a
nice new coat they're thinking well why
isn't that money that's totally totally
get off get it out yeah yeah yeah and
man if you want to buy a house buy a
house bro you're Miss out on the new
stock well cool I'm going to have a
place to live and I'll I'll let you rent
my garage yeah and the hard thing too
Nathan to John's point is like this plan
is not the exciting like flashy the
least sexy plan there is yeah it's not
going to be like oh yeah did you see
this thing that happened this we did
it's not I mean but it's the thing that
is going to sustain you because it not
only helps put you in a better financial
situation it helps you Nathan the person
as you're going through this of delayed
gratification all of it and people make
really unwise financial decisions
when they're
greedy and what what's the other one
when they're drunked and looking for
shortcuts yes so don't do that Nathan
play the long game and you're being so
wise at your age to do this so thank you
so much for the call thanks to all the
guys in the booth to make this happen
and you Emily Emily sorry Emily I see
you girl uh John thanks for co-hosting
and thank you America for listening this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
w
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with Ramsey personality and
bestselling author Dr John deloney and
we're here to answer your questions
America it's a free call anywhere in the
country at
5225 all right starting off this hour we
have a this is a good question Sean to
start us off on the Ramsey show we have
Gary Gary's calling from Phoenix hey
Gary Gary welcome to the show why you B
what's up dude thank
you thank you yes how can we
help well my question is I I listen to
your show and on car radio driving
around and when people do their debt uh
free scream and stuff if they're paying
off all their debts and everything
except for their house or and everything
including their house MH
they are making a significant raise
anywhere from 20,000 to 90,000 I can't
see them possibly working that many
hours of overtime to make $90,000 more
so can you explain what's going on here
for different things I mean that's great
but it sounds like too good to be true
yeah I could I could see that um I think
a couple of things are going on number
one I do think that they pick up extra
they pick up extra work I mean that is a
real thing side hustles have become a
big part of how people up their income
and two Gary uh I mean this isn't I
don't have specifics on this but there
is something to be said about somebody
that is so lasered in and focused on a
goal like getting out of debt that so
much of their time so much of their
energy is focused on it and when you
start to focus on one area of your life
that has been so out of control and you
start to see progress and you start to
actually see the movement that is
happening in the direction that you want
other parts of your life start to be
affected by that you start to actually
we because we get the we get the same
thing with um people when they do their
debt free screams people that lose
weight the amount of people that say I
lost 100 pounds in this process too uh
people that say our marriage has been
different these parts of their lives
that aren't correlated specifically to
money start to actually improve and so
for some people I mean you could even
take someone on commission when they're
so focused on something they're going to
be working so much harder and and as a
result be making more because they are
so focused and so lasered in and then on
the flip side too I think you know
employers even see that and we we hear
people all the time say I got a raise uh
because their work has been so effective
because they are so lasered in and
focused so I think it's a combination of
of a lot of that I'll also say just this
is all anic data so this I'm just trying
to Rack my brain here for all the de
free screams I've been a part of often
people decide like I want to get out of
debt and stay-at-home mom goes back to
work full-time or someone's just now
finishing graduate school and they're
entering into their job and so they may
have made $20,000 working part-time
through grad school and suddenly they
get their job and they're making 85 and
it looks like a strange bizarre jump but
it's really not so like for example like
for example for the last part of my
career when I was working uh I was
making like $30 an hour so I and 20,000
was in overtime so all that together in
one year was 80,000 but some of these
people getting a raise of 90s so it just
kind of sounds hard for me to what what
did you do that's great but you know
hey what what did you
do I uh I worked in utilities and uh
mainly on a Val crew okay yeah gas so
imagine you had put yourself in a
management
track and at the same time you decided
to get out of debt and you became super
laser focused and you did that work and
you left
the crew and you went to a management
track and then they put you into the
ownership group that's not a far jump
right I guess so yeah I can see where I
can see where you're sitting and
actually I appreciate this question
because I know that it gives
people um the one that sticks out in my
mind uh Rachel is the teacher there's a
teacher in New York City when they shut
down everything and she had all this
student loan dead I think in my head I
remember being over figures over 100,000
bucks yeah and she just felt trapped in
her apartment and so she started driving
early early in the morning and then she
would go teach Class via zoom and then
the second the computer closed she'd go
out deliver food all night into the
night and she paid off like in 1 some
crazy number and I remember thinking I
told her oh you're one of those people
that is just a curve Buster you ruined
it for everybody because now we have no
excuse right right right and so I can
imagine if I'm sitting there going I
just don't buy it now if I've worked on
a crew my whole career and I am a i i
turn wrenches and I'm amazing at that's
what I do yeah dude you're going to get
a raise of a dollar doar 75 an hour
you're going to go up to $4 an hour when
you get put in charge of the crew I can
see that being a hard jump y but if you
decide I'm sick and tired of being sick
and tired and part of that is I'm going
to give away my dream and I'm G to go do
the management track this yeah that's
the other thing people changing
positions because they're like oh my
gosh I could literally be making this we
cut our debt in half and for right now
it's not about me loving my job and
doing my passion it's about getting out
of Deb that's right we're going to jump
ship and we're going we're going to get
something that P more and we find that
too so a great question all right up
next we have Matt in orando hey Matt
welcome to the
show hey thank you for having me on how
are you absolutely do we're doing great
how can we
help all right so I have a um kind of
like a kind of like a unique question I
um so I've done pretty well financially
but I'm to the point now I'm just trying
to spend a little more money than I used
to and I'm very frugal and I'm kind of a
I sacrifice you know a lot and I've
saved up a lot and I I want to do some
more things with you know with my family
and I kind of look at like uh family uh
experiences is like a good way of
spending money and the money we're
spending is started to make me a little
nervous so okay couple things that we've
done recently like we're spending a
little B more on vacations and more on
uh some like season tickets for a
sporting event hey ke do me a huge favor
speak speak directly in your phone for
me I Amor I'm sorry Matt sorry sorry mat
okay
and I'm also having a um we're also
considering a house Edition like a large
one okay and it's it's it's it's a it's
a pretty large one so that being said um
I'm just kind of I don't really know the
metric you know how much you need to
have in order to spend this much and and
I hope maybe you guys can even help me
out yeah well when it gets down to the
point um when you have no debt you have
your emergency fund your are you is your
house paid off my house is paid off yes
okay so you guys are yeah living in that
baby step seven world you know it is all
about ratios so how much how much you
guys um have in your nest
egg so um in like Investments like just
like stock market and retirement we have
like 9.2 million give or take but I
don't check it every day like I used to
okay and how much are you making a
year um it's based on the year but like
the last few years it's been between
like 1.4 to like 1.7 yeah that's great
well done Matt what I got to know
brother what vacation are you
sweating well it's not one vacation but
like they kind of we we've been on some
really nice vacations but every year
we're kind of spending more so I was
kind of thinking to myself what's the
amount of money per year we can like
just allocate towards vacations that's
kind of like more my question if you
want to know the places I can tell you
but as far as like the vacations it's
kind of like first was like maybe 15,000
a year and now like last year was like
35,000 this year it's like 62,000 yeah
totally well what I I mean the way I
would look at it is allocating more not
just on vacation specifically but I
would be looking at what am I spending
what are we saving and what are we
giving all three of those buckets need
to have a um a percentage to them and
you get to put that percentage Matt do
it and you guys are fine let me just
you're fine I think you're fine I think
you can spend spend some of that okay
but make sure you're doing all three
things with your money you're
[Music]
fine
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and we got some news in
that meant is closing up shop come
January and it's going to leave about 4
million
budgeters uh out in the in the wide open
range John in the cold in the Christmas
cold come come to our warmth Ramsey
Solutions wow Rachel made that that that
sales real weird we come to
Rachel's warmth we have one of the best
budgeting apps the best budgeting app
every dollar it's one that I use uh when
I I checked it every day did my
transactions this morning tracking them
I I love it it keeps us we have a trip
coming up I was just telling John we're
going to be going to New York next week
and even planning that I'm like we have
a line item for New York and it's like
when the hotel you you pay half of it
when you go you know when you have the
deposit down that's in there and like
tickets to a show like everything is
there and it just helps you stay on
track know where your money is and it
just gives you a cents of control which
is just so powerful so if you want to
check out every dollar make sure to go
to Every
dollar.com and every doll premium
honestly is one of the best things that
you can do because it connects to your
bank you have uh Bank connectivity
paycheck planning so much op so many
options uh with every dollar premium so
make sure to check out that budgeting
app every dollar well and I I never used
mint but the way George explained it to
me is mint is was great at telling you
what you spend what you spent how to how
to it's a track yes yes it's like it's
like the old checkbook register right
right I paid for this and this is this
is you know this this is with was
withdrawn from my account every dollar
is so much more because it helps you
plan into the future and I love it that
it connects me and my wife can both be
connected to it so when I spend
something I know that she's going to see
she's going to see it she like John um
but it it it continues to connect us but
also you can plan into the future we
want to buy a car so every month we're
going to move money over to this and it
keeps a running T tally for us or if you
owe money it shows you as you're paying
it off which is amazing too right yeah
and when your bills hit with the
paycheck planning you can know okay when
my check hits on the 1 is that enough to
get us through the 15th what bills are
hitting between now and the 15th I mean
it helps you plan out your life so again
it's it's an incredible incredible
budgeting app and that is every dollar
all right up next we have Katon in
Spokan Washington hey Keaton welcome to
the
show hi guys how are you we're doing
great how can we help hi um I just had a
quick question here for you guys uh
regarding my student loan uh payments
here I'm just curious to know what's
what's the best way to uh attack my my
student loan uh repayments here um
upcoming okay how much how much do you
owe currently I have just under uh
27,000 okay um I do have I've been
saving up for the last few years to to
pay this off I do have
about 40,000 saved up um so I'm able
to yeah speaking to the phone for me
brother the phone yeah it's echoing oops
I'm sorry guys can you hear now we're
back okay um sorry about that um I have
about 40,000 saved up um to to repay uh
these student loans but I've had you
know family members and Friends kind of
give me their advice of the best way to
um to get rid of these student loans and
I was just curious what you guys thought
is the best way um to to do so uh the
best way is pay them off today I would
write a check right now when you get off
the phone yeah just just get rid of it
just get rid of it all all of it yep yep
I'm curious why does your family say oh
keep them they're so beautiful and they
give you so much joy and love in your
heart paying the last couple months I've
been paying um well above the minimum
payment I've been paying about $1,000
for for um for each month um essentially
what my mother says is that
um you know I guess you know it's better
to have that that money in case of you
know you know emergency or whatever
rather than just being out you know 27k
so I guess that's where um the
reservations come from what do you do
for a
living I work uh remotely I work for a
sales company um I make it around 125 a
year um don't tell me the name of it but
what's your product what do you
sell uh we sell uh telematic devices for
large Logistics logistics companies so
you can think of uh dash cameras and and
GPS units for large companies yeah so
Keon oh go ahead I was just gonna say um
I remember a few years ago when a lot of
people got sent home and then people had
to make their Q2 and Q4 numbers and
there's a lot of work from home layoffs
is that ever a possibility in your
world not not that I'm expecting our
company is actually doing um extremely
well um so I wouldn't foresee that
actually it's it's the the opposite
we're actually growing exponentially
right now um so things are are pretty
solid so I have a wired in this is this
is mean I don't want to project project
this into your world I just grew up in
Houston when there was this incredible
company one of the greatest companies in
human history called
Enron and they were always growing and
they were so amazing that they just
printed money it fell from the sky they
extract did it from energy sources was
amazing until everybody woke up one day
and millionaires just they went to bed
millionaires they woke up literally with
zero here's why I tell you that I think
there's a fallacy that the job is always
going to be there
unchanged that the one thing you know is
going to be unchanged is that you owe
the government
money that will never change they even
tried to do it went all the way to
Supreme Court it failed that's not going
to change and so I would look in my life
what are the 100% constants and I'll
start working down from that and even if
it's 99% chance that your job's going to
keep flourishing you're going to keep
crushing it keep making six figures
awesome that's still a 1%
differential from the guaranteed you're
going to owe the government money if on
the off chance that your company's the
next Enron which I'm sure it's not
but you get that call it says hey man we
got a um or that email that says hey
effective this this is going to be your
last paycheck thank you for your
service that student loan still due the
next month yeah yeah and and there is
something keting about having and it may
and it may feel a little different
because you have the money in the bank
just to pay it off if it got down to
like some crazy situation but John talks
about this a lot but there there is
something about just owing someone
something there's like this lack of
autonomy and when you just write a check
or you go online and you do the payment
and it's done like there is something
that you have this level of Freedom that
you just don't have right now this level
that I am not attached to anyone and I
have complete freedom and you end up
making other choices you know the
mindset your mom not to like bash your
mom's mindset but that mindset it is so
normal of just like hey keep that there
it's fine it's not a big deal and that's
the game people play day in and day out
and they don't realize how much of their
income is going to this debt how much
you're paying an interest now and all I
mean it and it's playing this game
versus saying you know what I'm going to
do an extreme situation that is not
normal I'm going to be completely
debt-free ke you're still G to have
$113,000 for an emergency fund are you
single uh I do have a girlfriend okay
but yeah not married no kids like that's
a that's a great emergency fund maybe
you can beef it up a little bit more if
you want and you're going to be able to
do a whole lot of things without ever
being tied to the government anymore not
having that line of debt and so there's
just something about cutting it out that
is going to give you a level of peace
that you almost don't even imagine
because you've been carrying it around
so long it's become so normal and that's
what people do all over especially with
student loans it's like the one type of
debt people are like oh my car loan my
credit card but student loans somehow
kind of just it's just the thing that
just stays around is what it feels like
and people just get so used to it and
when you finally get rid of it I bet you
ke there's something tonight because I
want you to do it today tonight that
you're just G like okay it's done now I
get to go back to my plan and saving up
for me and not sitting here and like
dealing with the government every month
what what is your take come every
month uh it it fluctuates um because I
work in you know sales so it's anywhere
between 10 to 12 thousand a month how
much do you send to student loans right
now um say that again I'm sorry how much
do you send to student loans right now
right now I've been say I've been
sending $1,000 a month okay um my
minimum payment is is around 250 is so
you get to do so so in 6 months Katon
did we did we uh I'm just curious say
yes or no real quick did we convince you
are you gonna pay it off today and just
be done with it yeah you know because I
you know i' I've you know been following
Dave's you know baby steps and I know
that this is you know part of the plan
is to you know attack you know your your
debt and just get rid of it once you
have it we got to go to a break but I
love it pay off did it PID off 6 months
you'll have 18,000 bucks you'll be good
to go
[Music]
w
so the holiday season always creates
conversation around stuff and what we
have and especially your parents out
there if you have kids and you got the
Amazon booklet with all the toys my kids
did and they circled every single thing
in it as I opened it and I was like oh
really children really is that is that
all is that all that you want is that
all that you feel like you need uh but
that contentment piece is is so huge and
it's one that I keep kind of drilling
into my kids I'm like you guys that
excitement my my six-year-old the other
day she just was so mad I put this I put
this St on Instagram but she was just so
mad in her room and I was like what's
wrong Caroline she's like I'm so mad at
brilliant Sky which is a toy store here
in Franklin I was like why are you mad
at brilliant Sky she was like there's so
many great toys and I can't have any of
them and I was like oh well I feel that
way about J crew I get it like I get it
I want all that stuff perfect time for
you to be like well honey I wrote a book
I know I know well I was like but it's a
constant conversation especially if you
have little kids in your life of like
you guys listen you can have the fun toy
but that excitement that you want out of
that fun toy fades in about 15 minutes
and especially the younger you are the
faster that Fades uh but it's true for
adults and kids and so yeah that is one
reason I wrote uh my book I'm glad for
what I have it's my first children's
book and it's out today it's launch day
and has beautiful illustrations it's so
fun but it's just a great book to remind
kids and adults the reader that stuff is
not bad but it doesn't fulfill you the
way you think it does so it's going to
be a great Christmas gift or even
Thanksgiving gift if you have kids in
your life so make sure to check that out
and we have other great meaningful gifts
for Christmas and at our $12 sale at
ramsy solutions.com store so there's
books like The Total Money Makeover baby
seeps millionaires own your past change
your future all for just
$12 and the questions for humans uh
cards that John has done is there for
less than $10 or as low as $10 and the
Christmas edition is back and those sold
out last year year so make sure to check
it out so some great stuff out there uh
to actually help create great habits
great conversations around your life and
your money for this Christmas so again
check it out at ramsy solutions.com
store hey real quick before we go to a
call I want to call this out for parents
out there so I took I take my son to
breakfast to Waffle House free
advertising there you go uh we go to we
go to Waffle House every
Tuesday not this Tuesday but last
Tuesday I am starting a pregame and I
said Hank this
year we're not going to buy 50 things
we're going to do a couple of things
here and we're going to do some
educational stuff cuz his mom and I are
nerds and we're going to have a couple
of clothes that kind of stuff some
museums yeah exactly just books and
things like that and he looked at me you
know what he said he goes yeah that's
exactly what you said last year I'll see
if you hold to it oh my God and so
really quick I was using my son in this
big announcement like hey Christmas is
going to look different but I was trying
to get my son to make me feel okay
because I have told myself a lie that
the only way my kids will love me and
the only way my kids will feel fulfilled
is if I buy a bunch of crap yep and it
was my 13-year-old going oh that's cute
dad cool um you always tell us that and
then you buy a bunch of stuff because
you're insecure he didn't say that but
but so parent we often point it to the
kids it's often us oh yes who try to buy
our way out of or buy our kids love or
to put stuff under the tree because we
feel guilty that we're always at work or
whatever we have to be okay with
ourselves too yes and maybe as we read
this book to our children we need to
absorb that message too that is that's
right that's I know that was one of my
goals in it and it's so funny even with
the Christmas conversation I remember
last year taking a picture of like our
Christmas setup cuz people do that on
Instagram and they're like CHR Christmas
Eve I know you hate it Sean and I did it
and I was like yeah we like I don't know
we had some good toys and everyone was
like I love the minimal Christmas oh my
gosh like that was every comment I was
like oh man did and for a sweat second I
was like did we not get our kids enough
stuff and then I thought no we had a
budget and I'm not going to go I'm not I
don't want to like load it with a bunch
of crap of Stu it's just toy stuff is so
annoying it just it's just gets
everywhere and it's like you got Sonic
toys that come dear God please be with
Rachel Winston they're clearly
struggling all of it I don't know it
just really funny so I feel like I
practice what I preach subconsciously
well how it was going forth this year so
good all right up next we got Ally in
New York City hey Ally welcome to the
show Ally are you there hi hey Ally
what's up here hi hi how can we help um
so um actually about a month ago I
purchased the Financial Peace University
stuff and um I was going to do it with
my husband um because we had got gotten
into some debt and things were not great
um but we had a plan and we were going
to get ourselves out of it um and he was
changing jobs and we had a really big
plan um and then he died about a week
ago oh honey and oh gosh Ally I'm so
sorry what happened which was itong
allly what happened I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know his yet
bill
bill so um I have children that I need
to take care of and things are changing
very quickly and our house was being
sold and I am going forward with that
plan because financially I really need
to do that so here's my point um I don't
like so there's like sort of the
traditional Financial Peace way of doing
things you know I um we didn't get to
start it but but I'm actually taking my
first class tonight and I um know like
what the steps are but um so much has
changed so quickly and I really need to
think about um do I buy a house for them
do I rent um I want to have some sort of
stability um I just have all these
really really major choices that I'm
being faced with and I don't know what
my first step should be yeah so this is
super super important number one I'm so
sorry I'm heartbroken with
you um I can hear it in your voice this
is a week
ago yes brand now okay um do you have
somebody that can hold your hand right
now no I I I have to be alone for a
little bit there's been a lot of people
around a lot and they're helpful they're
great but I have kids and I'm trying to
be um okay when I'm home so I try to
things when I'm out of the house okay a
couple of things here number
one the Great greatest gift you can give
your kids right
now is to let them see their mommy be
super super
s if you try to become perfect in front
of them become an iron statue of
strength and
stability they're going to feel that
humongous hole in their heart and
they're going to think they're
crazy and it sounds counterintuitive but
if they see mommy cry and they come sit
with Mom and y'all weep together
and then you say let's go get something
to
eat that's going to be the greatest gift
because they're going to know they're
not crazy they're just like their mommy
and their mommy's really really
strong okay yeah that's number one
number two the greatest wisdom I ever
got during some pretty profound loss and
as I've sat with people over the years
don't do anything permanent for six
months to a year if the house was
already being sold and that was already
in the works and that's the right
decision for y'all then fine please
don't run out and buy a house please
don't do that and everybody's going to
give you this and that and this the
stability quote unquote for your kids is
going to come from y'all it's not going
to come from a geographic location right
now
okay you're going to get a thousand
different pieces of advice please double
back on this one don't buy a house right
now because you don't know what six
months from now or a year from now is
going to look like when it comes to job
when it comes to moving back with family
when it comes to your business closes
who knows what it's going to look like
yeah it's the big decisions Alle and the
small ones like even FPU like if you
want to take that tonight you can or I
would even just wait on that like I
think that yes I want to make sure
there's food on the table and your basic
bills are covered so if you feel like
that's going to help you get a level of
stability that's great but even the
small tactical stuff with money I think
goes on the back burner even I think
right now Ally to grieve yes I I really
I I would take the pressure off and
again if you feel like you need that for
an educational standpoint that's fine
but I don't want you to feel this
pressure that you have to get every
single thing in order right now I think
the number one thing for you is to
grieve and to get this house sold
because it's in the process find a place
to rent make sure food is on the table
lights are on your Basics are covered
but I would sit in that for about two to
three months and then if you feel like
okay now I can start to actually
learn and and and and expand in that way
I would do that but if you'll hold the
line Emily's going to pick up um and
we're going to give you some stuff Aly
and we we are so sorry so
[Music]
sorry
our scripture of the day comes from
Philippians
4:12 I know what it is to be in need and
I know what it is to have
plenty plenty plenty
plenty that was my Southern accent
coming through plenty I have learned
learn the secret of being content in
every in any and every situation whether
wellfed or hungry whether living in
plenty there it is again Plenty or in
once thank you Paul in case you're
wondering America uh there is not a
reading quiz before accepting the job of
Personality plenty I was saying PL
plenty plenty I I sound like an English
accent or a Southern accent oh you sound
like you or like six Xanax into the
afternoon is what you sound like God
plenty what's so hard about plenty
plenty I don't know Bob saying I said it
okay I don't know it just sounded weird
when I said it anyways Jordan Peterson
says perhaps you are overvaluing what
you don't have and undervaluing what you
do because you might have PL PL PL PL PL
plenty PL planty planty planty that's
what you say when you walk into like an
apartment it has lots of plants it's
like it feels planty in feels a
little I don't know how many apartments
You' walked in and said that John but
good for you good for you well you guys
the ramsy show annual listener survey is
live now give us good ratings me and
John you know this this was a this you
just did a bang up transition there
between so I can't read but you should
vote me we want to know what you love
about the show we want to know uh what
you want to hear more about everything
around this show we want the show to be
helpful to you so knowing what you want
and what you like what you don't like
all of it is helpful to us so if you'll
take survey to 3 3789 or visit ramsy
solutions.com survey fill that out for
us because it helps us here on the
Ramsey Show so you can sign up today and
actually enter to win a $500 gift card
which is amazing so hey real quick off
that last call yes this is super
important um especially as we enter into
the holiday season unfortunately um this
will happen this will happen um holiday
seasons sometimes see a spike in people
who pass away for any number of reasons
and as the caller in the last call said
she didn't even know right didn't even
know please give your family the
greatest gift you can give them which is
a will this holiday season get a will
and life insurance yes and life
insurance separate from your job in that
last call he was transitioning jobs
moving from job a to job B
and please
please um do that one year my parents
got all three of us kids long-term care
insurance for themselves and we all
applauded it was the one of the greatest
gifts ever right
cuz we all were kind of quietly talking
likey if something happens to Mom like
do you got any money do you got like we
kind talking and that's what they got
for it was a what a gift yes even if you
tell your adult kids or your teenage
kids kids we got life insurance they
might go oh I wanted to Xbox but I
promise they'll be happy absolutely get
a will a will yeah Mama Bear legal forms
check them out and Xander insurance for
term life insurance yeah taking care of
your your family and this stuff you guys
it's a sometimes it's an awkward
discussion for people or they want to
face reality and maybe even your parents
you know like you were saying with your
parents John but having those
conversations and encouraging the people
in your life to have things taken care
of because um which is because life
happens and we see that all the time on
this show and just like Ally in the last
segment it's just terrible and
heartbreaking but when that stuff is in
order it gives some peace and stability
to a really hard and sad situation so
it's a great Point John all right up
next we have Beth in LA Los Angeles Hey
Beth welcome to the show
hi I'm actually just calling because I
need some
encouragement I have known about FPU for
years 16 17 years since I've been
married and for some reason it's just
taken me till June to finally get on
board and my husband get on board so we
paid off 23,000 but we have 83,000 to go
and I just feel like I've kind of laugh
that like drive not to keep going but
like I just need encouragement because
feel like we started too late with this
and there's just so many pressures going
on like not going to have enough for our
kids We're not gonna have a house
because we started too late so I just
kind of need like no you got this you
can keep going it's okay you're yeah
yeah how old are you guys
Beth um I'm 38 my husband's 40 okay how
old are your
kids uh three and seven okay so great
well for sure it's not too late let me
no let me just say that out loud and you
guys are in a hard journey Beth like
this isn't easy if it was easy everybody
would do this and you guys have just
started in June so you're kind of six
months in and a little bit of that
newness and the excitement of something
new has probably faded and you're
realizing oh my gosh like this is the
path that we're on for what how many how
many more years have you guys mapped out
this probably two more years um yeah
June January 2026 is what the plan date
is we're putting 3500 a month years
towards our death all right can I can I
ask you a hard question yeah why why are
Los Angeles why one of the most
expensive places on planet Earth to live
because it's where my family is not a
good answer what's another answer I know
God God keep bring God keeps bringing us
back here no hband and I have moved
around three different no you can't PA
that one off on God you keep getting
back in a moving van and going back to
LA is what you keep
doing I have a very good job though all
right how much do you guys make in a
year uh we make 10,000 a month after
taxes so I may bring in 116 and he's at
75 okay yeah so 120 after taxes yeah
yeah so Beth I mean I I think you know
this is a it's a marathon it's not a
Sprint and for where you guys are you're
right at that 24mon Mark that you have
24 months to go and continuing to put
your head down and just and driving it
down I mean it's it's it's amazing how
easily you can be distracted and
especially when you make great money I
me you guys are bringing home 120 um and
feeling like oh my gosh we work hard but
we're not able to go and do the things
we want to do with it it's that
continual going back going back going
back when things are hard going back and
I would celebrate along the way is this
83,000 is it broken up into multiple
debts yeah they're smaller yeah small
yeah so like have things that you guys
do as a family to to small celebrations
I mean it could be something as I don't
know maybe we obviously don't go out to
dinner but maybe it's like hey one night
we're going to go and enjoy a dinner out
or maybe we're going to go and do this
thing you you had the chains the the
visual things with the um the
construction paper John did but yeah I
mean finding finding these elements that
you can say okay we've checked that off
we've checked that off we've checked
that off but it's two years Beth I'm
like by the time you're 40 all of it's
going to be done it's not that long you
know that either I mean you've got this
and let me tell this there is that part
where I love that Rachel you said
Marathon because right as you were
talking here's what I thought of I
thought of the gun goes off in the
marathon and everyone is like waving
flags and it feels so great you're like
I'm going to run 26 miles and then
you're like you're at like mile three
and a half and you realize oh jeez I'm
tired nobody's cheering this weirdo's
breathing all weird behind me and I have
23 more miles and here's here's your
option you can quit or you just keep
putting one foot in front of the other
and so I think it's really important
that you and your husband map out like
the social norming part here there's
going to be some moments of excitement
like yes there's going to be some moment
of I hate you I hate money I hate
everybody there's going to be some like
if you ask me to have a stay in date one
more time I like I'm just going to set
the apartment on fire just to watch
something burn like this I want you to
know all those feelings are totally
normal you're not crazy you're not
broken okay this is a discipline March
from here on out it is I'm going to do
the right thing next month and I'm going
do the right thing the month after that
and I'm gonna I love what Rachel said me
and my wife had little little change
like when you're a kid and you're going
to like go on a ski trip or something or
Christmas is coming and we just put
every um every dollar amount we were
going to pay for the next X number of
months and we hung it in our bedroom it
was so ridiculous but I wanted it every
day that I woke up I want to see it and
we just ripped one of those things
off as you guys are pushing through the
hard this hard season this like slump
that you're feeling that's that's the
car that's the stuff where you're
continuing to say we're going to do what
we said we're going to do and that
discipline that's created in that and
not the flashy exciting moments of life
it's it is in the dirt and in the mess
and in the frustration but you continue
to do what you said you're going to do
that level of stability Beth and that
level of refining and that level of mat
charity is the Same Spirit that's going
to carry you guys when you start to
build wealth and Beth who's 50 who has
awesome money in her Roth IRA and she's
killing it and you guys are like living
the dream what you had and what you went
through in this process is the same
character that's going to hold you in
that so we believe in you we see this
every day you got this Beth you got this
well thanks to all the guys in the booth
including Emily John thank you so much
and thank you America for listening this
is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
n